wie ist die lage
die lage ist im moment sehr entspannt ja
eher die krise hat bei uns noch kein
noch keinen platz gefunden und du hast
die lage ist seit gut wie selten
eigentlich und ja ich kann nur sagen
leute macht sie wieso dann seid ihr auch
die mit der krise nichts am hut wie es
mit world of warcraft wie ist die lage
bei dir auch eigentlich sehr gut also
ich muss leider sagen ich habe jetzt
wieder so mein mann mein arbeitszyklus
aufgenommen so ich habe jetzt viele
viele monate eigentlich extrem
meine arbeit erstmal so brach liegen
lassen habe wenig gespielt auf bühnen
habe auch erst mal das studio gemacht
ein bisschen vermieden konnte das heißt
sie ganz nah durchzocken also ich war
seit
release des addons bis eigentlich zu
diesem monat dauert zocker bin
dementsprechend natürlich auch weil ich
ziemlich viel zeit investieren konnte
sehr weit auf den content und das ist
natürlich auch ein punkt also ich spiele
schon immer warcraft schon vor world of
warcraft habe ich dir warcraft teile
gezockt dann dementsprechend auch
command conquer und auch diablo und so
alles also alles eigentlich was aus
hause blizzard kommt aber damit world of
warcraft haben sie den vogel
abgeschossen und eben weil es hat eine
virtuelle welt ist in der ich mich dann
praktisch auch anonym bewegen kann das
war ein ganz großer punkt gerade ich der
wenig anonymität auch hat so ich ging
das dann für mich im urlaub wenn ich
spiele so bist du auch ein star in world
of warcraft oder ja also ich bin
aufgrund der der gilde und aufgrund
unseres radstandes bin ich ein
theoretischer star also wir sind
am content ende fast angekommen
sozusagen für die leute die das nicht
verstehen die sachen die du erreichen
kannst oder oder die gegner die du
sozusagen besiegen kannst in diesem
spiel in dieser welt die haben wir jetzt
fast alle besiegt sozusagen und das
zeichnet sich durch durch titel aus die
du bekommst die zu dem charakter namen
zugefügt oder dahinter
angegangen werden und natürlich auch am
equipment also an der ausrüstung die du
natürlich dann auch visuell einfach
erkennst abseits der werte die den
charakter sozusagen stärken
und da sehen wir alle natürlich gerade
meine gilde sehr gut aus und wenn wir
halt irgendwie alle kurzform raid
irgendwo mit 20 30 leuten auf einem
platz zu stehen sodann beim halt auch
andere spieler einfach mal stehen und du
siehst also virtuell wie sie sich
angucken so risse und manchmal wenn sie
halt klicken wollen rechtsklick so und
anstand kannst du entweder angucken
fluss sein oder ein laden in der gruppe
und salat aus versehen dich hat eine
gruppe einladen merkt okay da wollte ich
gerade angucken und falschen knopf
gedrückt heißt also es ist schon es gibt
natürlich eine gewisse anerkennung nur
allein aufgrund der anerkennung spiele
ich nicht weil diese vermeintliche
persönliche anerkennung die genieße ich
ja so in meinem beruf egal ob jetzt
positiv oder negativ und von daher
brauche ich jetzt warcraft nicht
sozusagen um irgendwelche so wie man es
gerne sagt halt menschliche schwächen zu
kompensieren also ich flüchte ich mich
zwar auch in eine gewisse welt aber ich
bin da sehr gerne und ich liebe das
spiel so wie es ist ja so wie du deine
freundin liebst und die hat auch
manchmal mundgeruch oder hat auch
irgendwie mal ist halt scheiße
geschminkt und so ist mit dem spiel
genauso ich liebe das spiel einfach und
so wie man hat seine frau liebt oder so
jetzt geht es aber kritik eine menge an
world of warcraft
was aber oft das phänomen dahinter
steckt das verwechselt wird mit sowas
wie wie ego shootern also schießspielen
was world of warcraft ja gar nicht ist
wenn man die geschichte sieht ist dass
er entstanden aus den rollen spielen die
ja schon in den 80er jahren zu hause im
wohnzimmer gespielt wurden mit würfeln
für habe ich vorlese karten und jemand
dass ich seit ich mach' ich habe
mitgespielt und städte rollen gespielt
und alles und schwarze auge und so was
ja damit als 13 14 jähriger habe ich da
schon gestartet aber man muss halt sagen
im endeffekt geht es halt so bei jedem
spiel darum dass irgendjemand irgendwie
erledigen muss eliminieren muss keine
ahnung was und jetzt nur weil das eine
irgendwie monster sind das andere
sondern irgendwie kleine schweine des
anderen menschen ja und bei warcraft
sind dann irgendwelche dämonen oder
geister so prinzip ist dasselbe aber
da steckt der teufel auch wieder im
detail ich meinen so man hat dann wieder
irgendwas und dann stürzt sich wieder
irgendein politiker mit einer aussage
oder ein großes magazin schreibt dann
irgendwie bericht über world of warcraft
und auf einmal sind das alles die
nächsten attentäter der schulen das ist
doch viel zu einfach aber das war ja bei
mir genau dasselbe also so einfach geht
das nicht und man muss dann einfach
differenzieren und wenn die leute
ein eine gesunde einstellung zum leben
haben dann werden sie weder durch
marilyn manson noch durch bushido und
noch zur world of warcraft und auch
nicht durch counter strike zu fördern so
das kommt auch bei world of ausgang ist
mein eindruck darauf an was so ein
umfeld man hat wenn man ein gutes
soziales umfeld hat wird man das spielen
aber wird abends auch wieder rausgehen
oder sonst was machen wenn man es nicht
hat bleibt man wahrscheinlich daran
hängen theoretisch ja nur dann ist es
auch wieder zwei ich hatte auch ein
gutes soziales umfeld hätte ich wenn ich
hatte kein gutes soziales umfeld und ich
war hatte natürlich auch eine
konfrontation mit gesetzeshütern und
sowas gehabt aber im endeffekt würde ich
doch mal tippen dass ich relativ
vernünftig bin bzw ich weiß wann ich
fehler mache und wenn ich einen fehler
mache oder wenn ich auch etwas
verbotenes mache dann weiß ich dass ich
das mache und ich trage auch dann die
konsequenzen das hat auch meine mutter
mir immer gesagt mach du bist ein
vernünftiger junge auch wenn du scheiße
baust du wirst irgendwann
vernünftig werden und mittlerweile dann
verstehst du weißt meine mutter auf
jeden fall das was wir wo
hast du denn nicht trotzdem das gefühl
manchmal hey das hält mich zu lange am
rechner ich komme hier nicht weg ich
wachse hier noch fest ich habe dieses
gefühl jeden tag ich muss mich manchmal
zwingen nicht zu spielen weil ich ja
manchmal sagen okay warte mal ich guck
mal kurz rein vielleicht habe ich im
auktionshaus verkauft oder einer hat mir
jetzt geschrieben oder irgendjemand sagt
mir hallo aber dann mache ich es nicht
weil ich dann eher wieder weiß ich
bleibe da drei vier stunden hängen oder
wenn ich dann doch mal kurz drin bin und
irgendwie einer schreib mir hey wollen
wir das so schnell machen und so dann
weiß ich so schnell ist das nicht und
ich brauche jetzt schon bestimmt fünf
stunden und wenn ich weiß ich
hab jetzt keine fünf stunden dann fange
ich es lieber nicht an
aber ich bin halt leider auch ein
ausnahmefall also mich nach zeit zu
fragen ist immer ziemlich schwierig da
ich selbstständig bin da ich auch
erfolgreich selbstständig bin ich habe
keine chef ich brauche keine
krankschreibung ja die jungs und mädels
die hier mit mir und auch für mich auch
arbeiten die auch alle sehr guten job
machen so wenn ich komme häufig ansage
ich komm nicht verstehe so
auch wenn das natürlich für die leute
mit denen ich verabredet bin natürlich
scheiße ist ja aber wie warcraft habe
ich schon mal gemacht ich habe
interviews abgesagt und hab mir gesagt
hey sagt einfach irgendwas so beschließt
also ich komme halt nicht und heute bin
ich extra gekommen weil ihr das auch
seit weil meine mutter die gerade im
krankenhaus ich meine das war jetzt nur
einen handgelenkbruch aber egal so und
ich bin gerade aus münchen über ruhm
gekommen und
habe jetzt kurz überlegt so fahre ich
jetzt einfach zu meiner mama ist ein job
ich komme jetzt erst mal her und ich
mache das aber wie gesagt ich kann
machen was ich möchte und deswegen kann
ich einfach wenn es hart auf hart kommt
drei tage fünf tage oder auch zehn tage
am stück spielen ohne dass das geschäft
leidet
und das ist geschäft leidet und deswegen
so da muss ich aber auch meine monat im
jahr arbeiten so weise aber wenn ich
diesen monat hinter mir habe dann dann
kann ich wieder zocken und wie gesagt
also ich versuche natürlich auch meine
ganzen hotelaufenthalte und so natürlich
so zu legen dass sie sagen hey ich
brauche internet auch wenn ich auf tour
bin sage ich in jeder location wo ich
ankommen dann brauche ich internet ja
weil ich brauche eine vernünftige
verbindung zum webserver und um einfach
das auch zu machen weil das ist ein teil
den ich auch pflegen möchte das ist ein
hobby von mir und
eines meiner hobbys mit den ich kein
geld verdienen aber ich finde das geil
so ich feiere ich bin einfach fan ich
bin richtig großer fan davon und
deswegen freue ich mich auch über alle
neuen news und ich bin jeden tag auf den
einschlägigen warcraft seiten und in den
foren und so und wie gesagt mein ganzer
freundeskreis für nämlich bescheuert so
viel lachen nicht alle aus und finden
das voll langweilig aber
ich habe mich so weit gehend emanzipiert
dass ich mir keine ausreden aus denke
für urlaub sondern ich sage ich kann
heute nicht warum
mittwoch 19 uhr
server reset ich muss dran also dein
second life ist quasi world of warcraft
mein verein beim hört leider meine
second life ist bushido und okay mein
drittes leben des warcraft wobei ich mir
nicht so sicher bin ob da nicht auch
manchmal so die gewichtung fällt das
dann second life warcraft ist und wird
live ist bushido weise also das wechselt
manchmal manchmal ist warcraft auch main
first love also aber das ist gut ich
brauche auch diese intensität alles
andere wäre für mich quatsch ich kann
nicht rein
20 minuten durch orgrimmar laufen und
dann wieder offline gehen also das geht
nicht das bringt mir nichts was bringt
keinen kick und ich brauche den erfolg
und wie gesagt ja ich habe das glück
dass meine gilde mit mir auch zusammen
sehr erfolgreich ist und ich trage auch
also ich spiele auch eine tragende rolle
und das macht mich auch stolz dann
möchte man auch irgendwie das ist ja
überall so erfolgreicher mann ist dass
du lieber macht man das was man macht
also so irgendwie zeitungen cover und
und gold platten und sowas bringt mich
dazu gewinnen dass sich immer mehr macht
und dann dreht sie plötzlich im film
oder schreibst auch noch ein buch und
das buch ist auch noch erfolgreich und
dann denkst du dir jetzt spiele ich mich
selber im kino wenn das erfolgreich wird
dann irgendwann denkst ich will
bundeskanzler werden also man muss
natürlich aufpassen dass man nicht
größenwahnsinnig wird aber genau ja auch
hat es gerade abgelehnt also der wind
nicht in die politik gehen ja ich hätte
noch nicht gewählt
da er soll lieber beckenbauer in die
politik gehen aber da wäre auch da eine
grenze wo sagen also dass er seit der
erfolg würde dich nicht so weit treiben
das war vielleicht könnte ich mir
überlegen in die politik zu gehen doch
doch natürlich ich meine so lange ich
nicht an größ größenwahn erkranke das
ist das für mich doch eine alternative
weil ich sag dir ganz ehrlich ich bin
jetzt 30 werde im september 28 31 und
ich will das ja auch nicht auf
lebenszeit machen ja also ich kann mir
vorstellen mit einem gewissen alter habe
ich keinen bock mehr auf rappen und
bravo cover und
bühne und auftreten und irgendwie durch
deutschland tummeln und so was ich will
jetzt noch mal schön meine grenzen
austesten irgendwie man auch mit dem
kinofilm dann werde ich konzerte im
ausland spielen ich habe meine flugangst
überwunden das heißt ich fliege nach
russland und so weiter und so fort und
machte hat jetzt noch ein paar jahre
richtig halligalli und dann auch ein
deutsch natürlich leute
und ich bin halt noch ein paar jahre
halligalli machen und irgendwann ist
dann auch ende gelände dann mache ich
familie mit mit hoffentlich vielen
kindern und meiner traumfrau und wenn
ich das auch wo man geschafft habe und
ich nichts zu tun habe so dann habe ich
mir überlegt ob ich erstmal
bürgermeister von berlin werde und wenn
ich das geschafft habe dann keine ahnung
man muss man gucken was ich alles machen
muss entweder bundespräsident oder
bundeskanzler oder so
oder generell politik einfach jahre
bundeskanzler ist ja alles hirngespinste
aber ich fände das okay weil ich mein
ich betreibe ja jetzt schon
meinungsmache meinungsmache mit meiner
musik viele leute hören mich ja auch
oder hören auch auf mich oder indem sie
meine cd kaufen ist es also werde ich
ihr meine stimme gebe deswegen ist ja
kein großer unterschied so ich kann
sachen bewirken in der musik ich kann
sachen bewirken der politik und mal
gucken ich meine ich denke mal so ich
bin es auch so ein prototyp so von vom
neuen deutschen auch oder auch
vielleicht auch von meinen politiker
weiß weil
deutschland sieht anders aus als vor 50
jahren ja und das müssen wir langsam mal
begreifen und im endeffekt
sage ich dann einfach so hör gut sondern
morgen doch jetzt einfach mal eine
politik kann auch sein dass sie keines
machen gerade wenn du so polarisiert und
auch so extrem auch auf der einen art
und weise bist musst du ja besonders
viel fingerspitzengefühl mit den
menschen haben da kommen ein paar leute
die haben auch vorteile dir gegenüber
und die habe ich auch selber
heraufbeschworen
ja ganz genau und auf der einen seite
würde ich gern etwas positives bewirkt
mit meiner musik auf der anderen seite
gibt es lieder mit denen wirklich etwas
negativer ist ja da gibt es sachen mit
karel gott wo dann wirklich wieder jeder
sagen dann ist es nett irgendwie der
ältere herr aus dem flieger heute von
münchen nach berlin und ich habe für
jeden irgendwie was im gepäck und ich
glaube das macht es ja auch irgendwie
sowieso der eine sammelt hasen der
andere legt hat irgendwie bosse in ulm
und der andere versucht sicherheit
irgendwie über ein handelsketten
freundin zu besorgen also ich
verschließe
wir machen alle das was uns gefällt und
solange wieder mit keinem schaden ist
das schon ok bzw man sollte sich
erklären können sagen was man so ja okay
gut dann wünsche ich dir dabei viel
erfolg dankeschön